madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 27 juillet
améliorer la vie des détenus et des
surveillants minimiser le stress de
l'enfermement tels sont les objectifs
d'elisabeth guigou dans son projet
prison 4006 nouvelles prisons doivent
être construites avec près de 3000
places supplémentaires
de nouvelles adaptations en corse dans
le cadre de l'affairé rignac les
enquêteurs recherchent toujours yvan
colonna le meurtrier présumé du préfet
au kosovo la commission européenne
chiffre le coût de la reconstruction de
la province alors que le conseil de
sécurité condamne le massacre de 14
paysans servent à graz co bernard
kouchner l'illustrateur provisoires du
kosovo sera notre invité en direct de
pristina et puis nous nous intéresserons
à tous ces bobos de l'été ses blessures
et ses urgences auxquelles les médecins
doivent faire face sur vos lieux de
vacances dans un village en épée se
transforme en une véritable petite ville
et puis enfin un coup de chapeau à la
française roxana maracineanu elle domine
allègrement le 200 m aux championnats
d'europe de natation en turquie il faut
dire qu'elle était quand même déjà
championne du monde
et d'abord les prisons et ce programme
prison 4000 décidées par le gouvernement
nous verrons dans un instant dans quel
esprit l'architecte sélectionné guillot
tran a conçu ces nouveaux établissements
pénitentiaires
mais en plus de la construction de six
nouvelles prisons elisabeth guigou a
annoncé hier la rénovation de cinq
autres établissements il s'agit des
baumettes de la santé de fleury mérogis
de fresnes et de la prison de loos les
lille où se sont rendus marianne masse
et patrick rostron
542 place 9 181 détenus et encore le
chiffrer bas suite au décret de grâce du
14 juillet la maison d'arrêt de loos
tourne en moyenne à 200 % de
surpopulation
à l'heure où l'on présente les futures
prisons de l'an 2000 on a plutôt
l'impression d'être au 19e siècle
d'un quartier de l'établissement qui
n'ont pas encore fait l'objet de
rénovations on est sur un programme de
rénovation des douches al'allure marée
qui a débuté en 95 et vous avez ici
c'est le dernier endroit pour lequel il
n'y a pas eu encore vas-y avant tout les
douches étaient dans cet état le
programme de rénovation aura pris trois
ans et ça n'est qu'une goutte d'eau dans
l'immense yankee de remise à neuf c'est
un établissement qui date de 1906 qui
après un gros retard sur le plan de la
rénovation et de la maintenance même si
maintenant année après année on s'en fou
à le rattraper il ya quand même un
retard assez conséquent donc l'état des
lieux est un état des lieux qui fait que
la situation est relativement tendu
où ils en sont quand même toile est à
réparer il ya beaucoup de théories d'eau
a monté sur autour des toilettes pour
que les autres codétenus il faut pas ce
qui se passe quoi ça va pas en quoi
c'est trop serré il faudrait faire deux
détenus par cellule ça irait ça passerai
mes trois c'est pratiquement
l'insoutenable 9 mètres carrés pour 3
personnes et seulement un surveillant
pour 100 détenus à laitages aujourd'hui
lens n'a pas les moyens de répondre à
tous les maux de la société le plan de
rénovation prévoit d'améliorer
l'hébergement la sécurité et les
conditions de travail gros problème
c'est qu'on nous fait toujours des
promesses et de l'os pour parler que de
l'os ça fait dix ans comme on dit et
qu'on rabâche toujours la même histoire
on va vous donner les moyens vous vous
donnez moyens le temps passe et on va y
arriver pour désengorger l'os une
nouvelle prison sera construite à
quelques kilomètres à peine ouverture
prévue fin 2012 dans ces conditions
minimiser le stress de l'enfermement
améliorer la vie des détenus autant que
celle des surveillants ce sont les
objectifs que se sont fixés l'architecte
guillot tron dont le projet a été
sélectionné dans ces prisons de l'an
2000 les détenus disposeront de douche
dans leur cellule et d'unité de visites
familiales tirer curtet et alexis dans
cette prison n'est pas seulement un rêve
darchy terre elle devrait apporter un
peu plus d'hygiène une douche par
cellule un certain confort 10 mètres
carrés pour deux et un peu moins de
stress en faisant entrer la lumière du
jour l'objectif fixé est simple ne pas
ajouter à la peine une sanction
supplémentaire due à la promiscuité et à
l'insalubrité chaque clic plus sera plus
libre de sa vie et donc cette qualité
qui va retrouver au niveau du quotidien
va se répercuter sur sambre son moral je
dirais et qui dit un détenu qui a bon
moral dit à une peine parfaitement
acceptée et donc une sérénité de
l'ensemble qui évitera tout le tout les
problèmes de mutinerie des meutes de
deux tentatives d'évasion de suicide
trois établissements identique à chaque
fois une maison d'arrêt un centre
pénitentiaire seront construits 4000
places pour sequedin dans le nord le
pontet dans le vaucluse et seysses en
haute garonne dans le même temps le
ministère fermera 1200 places
aujourd'hui inadapté on a beaucoup
construit ces quinze dernières années
quarante trois nouvelles prisons et pour
les observateurs du monde carcéral ce
n'est pas forcément l'unique solution
c'est pas en construisant de nouvelles
places de prison qu'on fera que la
surpopulation carcérale diminue en
revanche c'est en envoyant un peu moins
les gens en prison qu'on fera en sorte
que le temps carcéral soit utile pour
les gens qui sont incarcérés
parce que tout simplement on aura un
détenu par cellule et on aura le
personnel les personnels y compris à
travers sociaux nécessaires et
suffisants pour faire en sorte que ce
temps carcéral débouche non pas sur la
récidive mais sur une véritable
réinsertion dans la collectivité il y
actuellement 58 mille détenus pour 50
mille places dans les prisons françaises
le premier de ces nouveaux
établissements sera achevée en 2001
dans la sphère stranieri une nouvelle
perquisition a eu lieu dans la
discothèque où l'ancienne discothèque de
viry-châtillon là où les corps de
nathalie girard et frédérique admont été
retrouvé alfredo stranieri y assister il
est soupçonné de quatre meurtres selon
des scénarios identiques et il nie les
faits stéphane breitner maxime mieux
j'ai et gilles jaquet
ils arrivent directement de la prison de
fleury mérogis à l'intérieur du fourgon
alfredo stranieri et lorsque les
gendarmes le font sortir ses cachets
entre deux planches de bois qu'ils
entrent dans la discothèque de viry
châtillon pour cette nouvelle
perquisition le juge a refusé que l'on
voit le visage de stranieri les
enquêteurs eux commencent à fouiller son
passé quand on voit le personnage
sa part effectivement logique que l'on
cherche à savoir ce qu'il a pu faire ces
dernières années cette perquisition fait
suite à sa mise en examen pour
assassinat après la découverte de deux
cadavres dans le jardin la discothèque
et hier après-midi à son arrivée au
palais de justice une présence
inattendue le père d'une victime qui
crie sa haine ordures
j'aurai ta peau ordures dans son bureau
le juge a interrogé alfredo stranieri
sur les deux corps découverts il ya huit
jours ce sont ceux des anciens
propriétaire de la discothèque en
novembre 97 il avait signé un contrat de
location gérance avec ce même stranieri
depuis plus de nouvelles du couple sur
ce double meurtre le suspect ne donnera
aucune explication au juge la position
très ferme
je n'y suis pour rien je ne sais pas qui
a commis je ne sais pas pour qui ça a
été comme je ne sais pas si quelqu'un a
donné des consignes je ne sais pas je ne
tiens rien de ce qui s'est passé
alfredo stranieri avait adopté la même
position dans l'aveyron la semaine
dernière les gendarmes ont découvert
deux autres corps dans le jardin de
cette auberge là encore il s'agit des
anciens propriétaires ils avaient vendu
leur maison à stranieri en avril dernier
et là encore ils disparaissent après la
transaction pour les enquêteurs le
suspect utilise donc les mêmes méthodes
rachat d'un commerce avant d'éliminer
les propriétaires pour ne pas avoir à
payer stranieri possédait également huit
autres sociétés c'est dans cette
direction que s'oriente maintenant les
recherchent
en corse les enquêteurs recherchent
toujours yvan colonna l'assassin présumé
du préfet erignac
ce matin des à taper la scion et des
perquisitions ont eu lieu chez certains
de ses proches dans la région de calvi
yvan colonna lui reste toujours
introuvable agnès garder et olivier
théron
c'était le 27 mai dernier quatre jours
après avoir pris la fuite son portrait
était affiché dans tous les lieux
publics de corse deux mois plus tard
yvan colonna le berger de cargèse
l'assassin présumé du préfet claude
erignac court toujours avis de recherche
barrage filtrant à l'entrée et à la
sortie de cargèse sa ville natale tout
cela n'a donné aucun résultat
mais la police insiste convaincu
probablement que les bergers se trouvent
encore sur l'île ce matin dans la région
de tell vie les enquêteurs de la
division nationale antiterroriste ont
perquisitionné dans deux domaines
viticoles l'un des propriétaires ou
maurice acquaviva serait un ami proche
de colonna aurait-il trouvé là quelques
appuis dans sa cavale c'est ce que
cherche à savoir les enquêteurs au total
aujourd'hui donc six perquisitions et
trois hommes interpellés ils ont été
placés ce soir en garde à vue au
commissariat de bastia depuis
l'arrestation des quatre membres
suspectés d'avoir assassiné claude
erignac les gardes à vue s'additionnent
mais là aussi sans résultat il y à un
mois une reconstitution avait été
organisée sur les lieux du crime
l'opération a finalement tourné court
les quatre suspects ont refusé d'y
participer
ils sont depuis deux mois sous les
verrous dans les semaines à venir
perquisitions et gardes à vue pourraient
se multiplier dans l'entourage d'yves en
colonna car pour la police il est
difficile d'imaginer que le berger
réussissent à se cacher dans les maquis
corse seul et sans aucune aide
l'ancien préfet de corse bernard bonnet
lui doit être entendu vendredi au palais
de justice d'ajaccio sur la sphère des
paillotes par ailleurs on a appris que
l'un des conseillers de jean pierre
chevènement philippe barret a quitté le
cabinet du ministre de l'intérieur
officiellement ce serait pour des
raisons personnelles philippe barret
suivait particulièrement les questions
en corse à l'époque du préfet bonnet et
il lui avait apporté son soutien au
lendemain de l'agression de dominique
voynet dans les rue de dole par trois
hommes se présentant comme des chasseurs
on a appris que lionel jospin lui avait
téléphoné pour l'assurer de sa
solidarité et de son affection nous en
avons parlé tous les deux je vais en
amitié ma solidarité
et mon affection et puis elle m'a
expliqué un peu les circonstances dans
lesquelles cela s'était produit et
pourquoi aussi compte tenu de ces
circonstances
elle n'avait pas souhaité
comment dirais-je donner plus d'ampleur
à cette agression individuel extrêmement
déplaisante qui
qui lui a été infligée dont et dont les
médias ont parlé et pour être complet
sur ces questions sachez que le monsieur
chasse du gouvernement vient d'être
désigné il s'agit du député socialiste
françois patriat les verts ont aussitôt
fait savoir qu'il souhaitait un grenelle
de la chasse la question du port revient
à la une de l'actualité le mois dernier
le cours du porc avait été dopé par la
sphère de la dioxine en belgique mais
aujourd'hui avec la réouverture du
marché aux ports belges les cours se
sont effondrés au dessous de 6 francs 50
contre 8 francs 50 en juin colère des
éleveurs de porcs même si le
gouvernement belge vient d'annoncer
qu'il s'apprêtait à racheter une partie
des produits porcins encore suspects
olivier sioux et gabriel kamya
-25% en à peine un mois le cours du porc
est à nouveau reparti à la baisse 6
francs 45 hier contre 8 francs 50 en
juin de quoi remettre en cause la sortie
de crise qui s'annonce est à l'origine
de ce retournement la fin de l'effet
dioxyde avec le déstockage de la viande
belge la baisse des aides à
l'exportation vers la russie mais aussi
l'arrivée sur le marché français de
concurrents européens que l'on
n'attendait pas
la surtaxe américaine de 2 sur la viande
de porc danoise risque de pénaliser un
peu plus les producteurs européens
puisque cette viande donc risque de me
revenir sur le marché européen et donc
faire pression un peu plus sur le prix à
la production une inquiétude relayée par
toute la filière porcine qui se tourne à
nouveau vers les pouvoirs publics et
réclame des actions concrètes contre les
sanctions douanières des états unis
que le ministre fasse valoir entre
autres à bruxelles et dans les instances
mondiales halloween c'est quand même
qu'ils stoppent ce lien dmi absolument
inadmissible que d'une situation et
d'une volonté de diktat américain se
sont encore une fois de plus quelques
productions qui sont le fleuron de
l'agriculture française qui en subissent
les conséquences dans la foulée la fnsea
annonce des actions contre les intérêts
américains en france la fnsea michel
cheval en est lui aussi un militant
actif mais à contre-courant des
positions officielles de son syndicat
n'hésite pas à évoquer le sujet tabou la
maîtrise de la production il faudrait
faire une maîtrise d'oeuvre européenne
parce que si aujourd'hui on perd des
marchés à l'export et que l'on laisse la
production
augmente et on amplifiera ce phénomène
de crise les nouveaux rebondissements de
la crise belge apporteront sans doute un
répit technique relevé bart français
mais il risque surtout d'enterrer une
nouvelle fois toute velléité de maîtrise
de la production
le président de la fnsea le oui au
président qu une rentrée chaude à jean
glavany le ministre de la culture si
rien n'est fait pour rendre confiance
aux agriculteurs il faut dire que la
bagarre commerciales entre l'europe et
les états unis ne fait rien pour les
rassurer pour l'instant l'organisation
mondiale du commerce a donné raison aux
états unis qui sanctionne donc la
décision européenne de refuser
l'importation de boeuf aux hormones
américain mais dans cette bataille
l'europe vient de marquer un point
puisque la même organisation mondiale du
commerce estime cette fois que le
système fiscal américain favorise trop
certaines entreprises et spots
exportatrices des pratiques déloyales
qui représenterait une aide directe de 2
milliards de dollars aux exportateurs
américains
à l'étranger c'est d'abord la relance du
processus de paix au proche-orient et
août barak et yasser arafat se
rencontrent en ce moment même au point
de passage d'erez à la frontière entre
israël et la bande de gaza
les deux hommes se sont déjà vus deux
fois depuis l'arrivée du premier
ministre israélien au pouvoir mais c'est
leur première véritable séance de
travail après trois ans de gel et ehud
barak veut donc reprendre le processus
de paix mais il entend renégocier
certains aspects de l'accord de wye
plantation notamment le rythme du
retrait israélien de cisjordanie
ce dont ne veulent pas entendre parler
les palestiniens les enjeux de cette
rencontre avec notre correspondant à
jérusalem
charles enderlin
c'était hier à la knesset ehud barak
répète qu'il appliquera tous les accords
conclus par les gouvernements précédents
notamment l'accord de wye river que
benyamin nétanyahou son prédécesseur
avait signé à la maison blanche avec
yasser arafat
un accord qui prévoit trois retraits
israéliens successifs de cisjordanie en
tout l'autorité palestinienne devait
avoir sous sa responsabilité plus de 40%
de ce territoire dont elle ne contrôlent
aujourd'hui partiellement que 28%
monsieur netanyahou a suspendu
l'application de cet accord après un
premier retrait limité et puis les
palestiniens attendent toujours le
corridor de libre passage sur le
territoire israélien entre la
cisjordanie et gaza qu'il aurait promis
depuis 1996 et la libération de
centaines de prisonniers politiques
détenus en israël monsieur netanyahou
avait fait relâche et surtout des droits
communs les palestiniens n'avaient pas
apprécié ce n'est pas tout dès les
premiers accords d'oslo israéliens et
palestiniens s'étaient engagés à éviter
toute mesure unilatérale
or la colonisation se poursuit de plus
belle en cisjordanie et à gaza monsieur
barak n'a fait évacuer qu'une seule
parmi les vingt nouvelles implantations
construite à la hâte par les colons ces
derniers mois avant la rencontre les
dirigeants palestiniens étaient plutôt
inquiet yasser arafat a très mal
accueilli la proposition de monsieur
barack d'apporter des changements aux
accords de wye river ils exigent
l'application dans les plus brefs délais
de tout ce qui a été conclu avec
benyamin nétanyahou à washington en
octobre dernier la discussion avec
monsieur barack s'annonçait difficile
le kosovo le conseil de sécurité
condamne le massacre de 14 paysans serbe
à graz kohler obsèques devraient avoir
lieu demain une fois les autopsies
terminée des autopsies pour lesquelles
bernard kouchner a accepté la présence
d'un médecin légiste de belgrade nous
recevrons dans un instant
l'administrateur provisoire du kosovo
qui nous attend après cina mais la
sécurité et la cohabitation entre
communautés reste bien sûr le défi
principal auquel il doit faire face
selon la chair plus de 173 milles
non-albanais ont déjà fui la province
dans la région de christina les tsiganes
ont préféré se regrouper dans des camps
sous la protection de la kfor pour
échapper à la vengeance des albanais
reportage d' agnès vahramian et de
jean-françois redoute
c'est avec nous que ferrite ibrahim y
revient chez lui il s'est enfui il y à
un mois sa maison n'avait pas encore
brûler s'ils gagnent ses ancêtres venus
d'égypte se sont sédentarisés ici il y a
plusieurs siècles au kosovo les gitans
parle à la fois très bien l'albanais le
serbe est historiquement ils ont
toujours été utilisés par les plus forts
j'ai reçu une récompense est vrai qu'on
vivait avec les serbes ici il n'ya que
des maisons serbes
vont habiter très bien avec eux oui
c'est vrai moi j'ai toujours vécu avec
les serbes
les voisines serbe de ferrite l'ont pas
perçu elle lui explique qu'ils sont
encore quelques-uns des vieux à rester
là
personne ne vient voir si on est encore
en vie les albanais nous chassent en
porte tous les je ne sais pas jusqu'à
quand ça va durer
nous sommes la poussière du kosovo dix
les tsiganes autant dire peu de choses
pendant la guerre les serbes les ont
mobilisés en uniforme yougoslave il
exécutait les belles oeuvres de l'armée
servait de fossoyeur alors quand les
serbes leurs protecteurs sont partis
sepsi gagnent sont entrés dans des camps
réfugiés à leur tour tout près de chez
eux disent ils ne sortent pas essuyant
jets de pierres et insultes des albanais
pour autant ces rythmes n'affiche pas de
solidarité avec les cela ils portent
insiste-t-il un non albanais sa religion
et musulmane
je suis de sig and aime-t-il répéter et
je ne veux pas être enterrée par les
orthodoxes je veux partir à l'étranger
ni livre avec les albanais ni livre avec
les cerfs la kfor qui les protègent
finira-t-elle par raccompagné 7 sig à
nos frontières comme les serbes ils
partent famille après famille dès qu'ils
peuvent enlevant tout espoir aux nations
unies de réconcilier les peuples et du
kosovo
l'autre tâche urgente pour bernard
kouchner c'est bien sûr la remise de la
province en état de fonctionnement les
maisons les écoles les centres de soins
les réseaux d'eau et d'électricité ont
été détruits ou endommagés la commission
européenne a prévu d'y investir 140
millions d'euros en urgence mais ce sera
bien sûr insuffisant et dans les médias
se sont encore souvent les troupes de la
kfor qui pare au plus pressé valérie
fournioux effraye basket l'arrivée à
mitrovica re de deux bennes à ordure
offerte par la ville de paris un
prétexte cérémoniel de plus pour réunir
serbes et albanais
c'est un jour pour 12 équipes
travaillent ensemble partout dans la
ville et il fallait bien général comme
maître de cérémonie car la situation
devient critique
faute de moyens et surtout faute de
coordination entre des deux communautés
dès leur arrivée les troupes du génie de
l'armée française ont fait des poubelles
l'une de leurs priorités et les dépôts
d'ordures
clandestins dans la rue la rue larivière
donc de fait avec l'accord de la
municipalité nous a pour le terrain on a
prévu de faire une décharge de rentrer
kg propre et le vaincu le réseau
électrique n'a pas beaucoup plus fière
allure que les rues du vieux de 50 ans
et à peine entretenu depuis dix ans le
génie doit souvent rivalisé d'invention
pour remplacer un simple poteau il aura
fallu deux jours pour trouver celui ci
c'est une denrée très rare la preuve ah
oui l'état donc celui ci enfin trouvée
pour pouvoir permettre de rehausser
cette ligne électrique et menaçait de
tomber sur cette route voici la station
de pompage de la région momentanément à
l'arrêt les coupures de courant sont
fréquentes
d'autant plus que l'électricité provient
ici de serbie ces pompes à eau sont usés
obsolètes d'ici quinze jours elles
seront remplacés gratuitement par la
société générale des eaux en attendant
ces ingénieurs géré la crise
on essaie de traiter dans l'urgence des
sujets les plus épineux
fonctionnant à peu près normalement ça
demande des investissements énormes et
je suis en train de voir auprès des
bailleurs de fonds comme la communauté
européenne ou les nations unies pour
essayer de mobiliser un financement nous
prendrions à notre charge l'assistance
technique et dé mission de diagnostic
et que tout le réseau de canalisation
est à refaire ou presque laissée à
l'abandon depuis dix ans par l'ancienne
direction serbe il fut à 50% la nouvelle
direction albanaise a donc lancé des
restrictions
c'est assez compliqué c'est d'ailleurs
je dirais un des points qui est
difficile parfois pour la communauté
albanaise puisque une partie de ses
responsables a été limogé à partir de
1990 donc il ya une perte de savoir
faire qui est en train de se réaligner
de se ré acquérir et auquel nous
contribuons par par le notre soutien
malgré tous ces efforts l'eau n'arrive
toujours pas dans toutes les habitations
et c'est albanais ont fort m
annuellement jusqu'à 8 mètres de
profondeur pour rejoindre la nappe
phréatique le moyen encore le plus sûr
d'avoir de l'eau dans la région de
mitrovica
bernard kouchner bonsoir vous êtes à
christina vous avez donc été nommés
administrateurs provisoires du kosovo le
le 2 juillet et peu de temps après votre
arrivée vous avez donc elle faire face à
ce drame de graz qu on vous a entendu
supplié les serbes de rester leur
demander pardon est ce que font il n'est
pas trop tard
non je ne crois pas
en tout cas nous devons penser et nous
devons affirmer qu'il n'est pas trop
tard
que nous sommes venus ayant pour
protéger une minorité
pour protéger la minorité des minorités
même si c'est difficile et même s'ils ne
voulons pas mentir je vous dirais que la
protection des serbes et des tziganes
dont vous avez parlé
ne tient pas la police et ne tient pas à
l'armée elle tient elle tiendra
éventuellement à la transformation des
mentalités à la baisse de la haine de
l'avresne ici ressenti
est au commencement de démocratie qui se
fait jour
kouchner il ne reste plus selon les
chiffres il n'en as plus que trente ou
quarante mille serbes sur les deux cent
mille que comptait la province au au
départ est-ce que c'est pas une utopie
de parler encore d'un kosovo
multiethnique vous y croyez
d'abord j'y crois deuxièmement j'aurais
voulu vous entendre en parler plus tôt
nous sommes venu très tard mais nous
sommes venus
c'est toujours facile de critiquer
la critique est facile mais l'art est
difficile vous savez il ya des siècles
que pèse l'histoire ici très
particulièrement ici en europe alors
nous sommes persuadés qu'un jour ça
reviendra que les gens se parleront mais
il ya quatre mois personne ne pensait
que ça irait si vite personne ne pensait
que les réfugiés reviendrait civique
personne ne pensait à la reconstruction
alors laissez nous un peu le temps pour
que l'onu se met en place et puis la
conscience internationale aussi qu'ils
ne voient pas nous abandonner parce que
ça va trop vite oui c'est difficile
donc vous croyais très difficile vous
croyez votre mission vous croyez vous
croyez bien sûr à votre refus de votre
mission vous croyez à la faisabilité de
votre mission quelles sont les urgences
les plus criantes en ce moment au kosovo
ce à quoi je crois moi même
n'a aucune importance mais j'ai un
devoir une mission à remplir c'est de
tenir compte de cette résolution qui
s'appelle la 12 144 est derrière ce
chiffre qui a l'air ridicule des spas
qui n'est pas ridicule il y à l'onu il
ya une démarche mondiale pour que
cessent les atrocités le racisme et les
violations des droits de l'homme oui j'y
crois et vous allez voir nous le ferons
encore une question bernard kouchner y
verrons mais une question qui va vous
sembler critique mais on en parle
beaucoup effectivement de l'onu on
critique beaucoup la lenteur avec
laquelle la police se met en place est
ce que vous ne craignez pas d'être
d'être pris de vitesse par parle de
cheka qui a l'air de composer sa propre
police et est de mettre ces structures
elles-mêmes en place aussi
moi je ne crains rien monsieur j'essaie
de faire quelque chose et puis vous
savez
si vous vous reporter à ce qui s'est
passé après la guerre en france nous
allons beaucoup plus vite et puis si
vous essayez de réfléchir à ce qui s'est
passé en italie et puis dans le reste du
monde et puis en bosnie et puis en
macédoine et puis en somalie et puis en
angola nous avons été très vite selon
c'est pas simple les gens pour se parler
il leur faut un peu de temps
laissez nous faire ça aidez nous ne vous
critiquez pas trop d'un double les
moyens de le faire vous allez voir un
jour ça réussira bon c'est tout ce qu'on
vous souhaite et c'est tout ce qu'on
nous souhaite d'ailleurs par la même
occasion bernard kouchner merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous en direct de
prestige ce soir et merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions bonne soirée au
maroc on a appris aujourd'hui que les
hôpitaux de rabat avait dû soigner plus
de 1500 personnes au cours de la
cérémonie des obsèques d'hassan ii il y
a eu dix blessés graves 50 blessés
légers et 1500 personnes qui se sont
évanouis au passage du cortège philippe
rochot et philippe louzy se sont rendus
à moulay idriss ville sainte au nord du
pays où repose le fondateur de la
première dynastie marocaine
elle domine les champs d'oliviers à
perte de vue la ville sainte de moulay
idriss a vécu cruellement la mort du roi
hassan ii car cette cité de 12000
habitants en ferme le tombeau d'un homme
idriss descendants comme hassan ii de la
même lignée du prophète mahomet est
vénéré pour avoir unifier le pays
cinquante mille pèlerins viennent ici
chaque année mais après la mort du roi
voulait idriss est devenu doublement la
cité des pleurs
ce n'est pas un moment à vivre monsieur
ça ceci vraiment une qualité c'est une
catastrophe c'est une apocalypse pour
nous vraiment c'est une apocalypse pour
tous pas seulement pour les manques pour
toi pour le monde entier
après deux jours de deuil total le
travail reprend lentement dans la ville
sainte moulay idriss vie de l'artisanat
et de la culture des olives mais aussi
de l'argent des pèlerins qui viennent
parfois de libye d'algérie ou du sénégal
ce petit monde du travail se prépare à
présent à vivre sous l'autorité
temporelle et spirituelle du nouveau roi
mohamed6 qui devient donc à son tour
commandeur des croyants comme l'était le
roi hassan ii mais il est bien accepté
un bon images sur lui parce qu'il est du
qui s'est passé lui qui a indiqué lui
même c'est leurs droits cndd qui a
indiqué ce sans fils on a un grand
espoir pour lui travailler 100 m le
nouveau roi plus t-il ainsi être menacée
par les islamistes les ures du mouvement
du sheikh yassine ont estimé que la mort
d'hassan ii ne mettaient pas fin au
système c'est qu'il avait réussi à
contenir les débordements de l'islam et
cela rassuré les pratiquants d'un islam
traditionnel comme les gens de moulay
idriss mais ce qui attriste encore plus
les habitants de moulay idriss c'est de
savoir que le roi hassan ii devait venir
ici pour inaugurer le moussem la fête
religieuse traditionnelle et que bien
sûr il ne sera pas là et le successeur
de da scène de mohamed ci s'adressera à
son peuple le vendredi jour de la prière
en algérie à la veille de la visite
d'hubert védrine les algériens attendent
beaucoup des résultats de la mission
technique d'air france qui se trouve
actuellement à alger de cette visite
dépendra la reprise ou non des vols
interrompus depuis la prise d'otage de
décembre 94 une reprise très attendue
pour l'instant air algérie est la seule
compagnie à desservir le pays et ses
moyens sont notoirement insuffisant
compte tenu de la demande jérôme
baugnies c'est devant les agences d'air
algérie où il est difficile d'obtenir
des billets qu'on espère le plus le
rétablissement des liaisons air france
avec l'algérie
à deux heures du matin pour pouvoir
rentrer à à midi à avoir leur billet à
huit heures du soir
chaque année pour les algériens qui
veulent passer leurs vacances au pays
c'est la loterie malgré ses efforts et
l'algérie ne peut répondre à la demande
pour une dizaine de vols par jour
uniquement sur alger et hollande dans le
iii au cap depuis le détournement
sanglant d'un airbus d'air france fin 94
air algérie est la seule compagnie à
effectuer des vols quotidiens sur
l'algérie c'est aux yeux du nouveau
président bouteflika un véritable
embargo qui l'a dénoncé en juin dernier
lors de la visite à alger du ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement
lourde responsabilité sur les épaules de
cette mission technique d'air france ses
experts doivent scruter les conditions
de sécurité à l'aéroport houari
boumédiène pour déterminer si un
rétablissement des vols air france
serait raisonnable les syndicats de
pilotes français sont plus que
sceptiques
nous pensons que les conditions de
sûreté même avec le changement intervenu
en algérie ne sont pas à l'heure
actuelle à respecter pour une desserte
absolument sûrs de l'algérie
une mission technique d'alitalia a été
très satisfaite de ces conditions de
sécurité dans tous les cas il faudra
attendre octobre ou novembre avant que
les avions européens reprennent leurs
vols vers l'algérie
mais dont vont maintenant en france avec
la bobologie des vacances ça peut faire
sourire mais des villages comme celui de
vallon pont d'arc dans l'ardèche qui
compte habituellement 2000 habitants
l'hiver se retrouvent brutalement avec
35 ou 50 mille personnes à soigner pour
les médecins généralistes du lieu il
faut alors faire face aux petits bobos
bien sûr mais aussi aux urgences benoît
thévenet et jean yves blanc sous le
soleil de vallon pont d'arc il n'y a pas
de vacances pour les généralistes du
village les trois associés gilles
richard et philippe font même appel
chaque année un quatrième médecin alexis
ce matin la journée démarre sur les
chapeaux de roue 7h45 un vacancier vient
de faire un choc anaphylactique une
réaction allergique grave suite à une
piqûre de guêpe une injection
d'adrénaline permet de faire remonter la
tension du malade qui en est quitte pour
une journée d'observation à l'hôpital
local c'est quelque chose qu'on soigne
rapidement facilement 6 tentés tournée
sur place au bon moment j'aurais pu
serait beaucoup plus mal se passer c'est
si on n'avait pas j'ai aussi vite
de 8 heures du matin à 23 heures le soir
les quatre confrères travail à temps
plein en consultation en urgence au
domicile ils font chacun une quarantaine
d'actes par jour au lieu de 20 l'hiver
au programme beaucoup de coups de
chaleur ce bébé néerlandais supporte
apparemment mal les 35 40 degrés à
l'ombre il a un peu de fièvre et les
parents veulent être rassurés avant de
reprendre la route le lendemain pendant
ce temps au cabinet alexis diagnostic
une otite une de plus elles sont très
fréquentes à cette époque de l'année à
cause des baignades dans l'ardèche on va
en profondeur donc on fragilise son
tympan par la pression ligot de
l'arrivée un tympan qui devrait un petit
peu inflammatoire de l'eau qui est au
fond avec des bactéries qui se
développait une température idéale de
37,2 et ça fait des otites
invariablement on a comme ça des cas on
va avoir un tête 7 ou 8 audit par jour
un autre camping un autre médecin
philippe mais la même maladie une otite
l'été avallon la médecine se pratique
souvent dans la fournaise d'une caravane
et dans un anglais aux accents du sud
il demandé les télés généralistes
soigneux de tout mais surtout ce qu'ils
appellent la bobologie
rien de grave mais ça près des gens sont
en vacances il faut se faire servir
voilà ce soit au restaurant on sait
servir on va chez le docteur on sait
servir également donc on appelle pas
grand chose plus qu une otite sinon
c'est douloureux toute la nuit l'enfant
à se faire il faut le voir là y'a pas de
problème mais
c'est vrai que souvent quand même via un
petit peu d'écrits la journée avance
pendant que richard parent visite chez
un patient habituel
gilles des faits un plat
et dans la pièce d'à côté alexis en
pause un autre
à saint remèze un village voisin les
chars vient voir marius un ardéchois
pure souche qui souffre d'une bronchite
chronique et vallonné où les gens du
pays appelle peu le médecin et viennent
plus aux cabinets il laisse la factory
c'est de passer pour revenir en
septembre tesla en fait monsieur manier
vous l'été vous avez vous appelez moi un
médecin ah oui là ça va j'ai pris ce
dangereux par poulet
je sais qu'il est pris dans les gorges
parler il a des blessés jadis aux noix
les accidents de la route
et ce passage chez le vieux marius
amateur de truffe c'est comme une pause
dans les folles journées touristiques de
l'été ce sont ces contrastes que les
médecins de vallon pont d'arc sont venus
chercher en s'installant en ardèche
un mot de football avec le suspense qui
se poursuit autour du transfert de
nicolas anelka a arsenal on dit que les
négociations sont maintenant terminées
que nicolas anelka restera en angleterre
faute d'avoir trouvé un accord mais du
côté de la lazio de rome ont dit que les
choses ne sont pas finis aux
championnats d'europe à istanbul on
attendait beaucoup roxana maracineanu et
bien la française n'a pas déçu elle
s'est facilement imposé en finale du 200
m dos donnant sa première médaille d'or
à la france christelle bertrand
lors pendu à son cou roxana maracineanu
la plus petite du podium a été la plus
grande sur 200 m dos la française
d'origine roumaine a ajouté à son
palmarès une médaille européenne
maracineanu diminué par une angine en
début de semaine n'a pas laissé ses deux
rivales allemandes lui voler la vedette
au milieu du bassin dans la ligne jaune
la française sacrée championne du monde
de la spécialité 18 mois auparavant a
largement dominé la compétition
continentale maracineanu s'imposant de
11,94 avec plus d'une seconde d'avancé
sur l'allemand tenant du titre son temps
ne bat pas un record pour nager plus
vite il aurait fallu être mieux entouré
en fait j'ai fait ma course tout seul
puisque j'ai pas j'ai pas eu l'occasion
d'avoir les deux allemandes à côté de
moi puisque ont été les trois ans
n'aurait pu faire petit nuance un peu
plus rapide que stats mais on avait un
côté des hommes mais
moi ça m'a permis de gagner puisque mon
patron but de la tête était un peu loin
c'est ce qu'elle vient de dire
l'alliance
dans le chapitre on n'est jamais mieux
servi que par soi même stefan perron
bonnet blanc en bas de l'écran améliore
son propre record de france du 100 m
brasse le cannois remporté in extremis
la médaille de bronze c'est le premier
français médaillé en brasse depuis 1950
et avant de refermer ce journal je vous
fais part de cet accident de rafting qui
a eu lieu dans le canton de berne en
suisse pour l'instant la télévision
suisse parle d'une douzaine de victimes
le principe au titre de l'acuité ce soir
c'est ce qu'annonce elisabeth guigou la
construction de six nouvelles prisons
avec près de 3000 places supplémentaires
et la rénovation de cinq autres
établissements améliorer la vie des
détenus et des surveillants et minimiser
le stress de l'enfermement tels sont les
objectifs de la ministre de la justice
dans son projet prison 4000 voilà dans
un instant la météo ce sera nathalie
rihouet à 20h50 le temps d'une chanson
présentée par frédéric mitterrand le
dernier journal vers erreur 50 frédéric
protat demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevra jean claude
gayssot le ministre des transports à 13
heures ce serait bien sûr carole
gaessler et rachid arhab et j'aurais
quant à moi le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain soir aux alentours de 20h bonne
soirée évidemment sur france 2